hello ladies and gentlemen Ryan ride
presenting himself
Breanna white also here yes I don't have
permission from this guy he did not send
me four separate messages telling me
that it was totally okay to use his
video I didn't get something on Twitter
from him I didn't get something from
Facebook I didn't get a private message
or an email but here we are today I'm
gonna use this whole video he did
actually get permission me want you know
I do do actually really I wanted so many
people to hate on me for not getting
permission yeah but they're gonna do
that anyway yeah that's true I get ya
what decision anyway although Jones
weird trailer Suicide Squad I've gotten
a lot of comments saying we should watch
this especially because what was last
when we watched we watched Batman V
Superman be Superman weird trailer so
I'm very excited for this one I heard
that we had a cameo in it from a lot of
comments you did I know I have a cameo I
don't know if you have a cameo I know I
got one he'll be working you're done
okay
well all look you know I'll keep an eye
out for it okay here we go
most Luthor one the worst yeah
hail to the uncle most dangerous people
on the planet looks real yeah it easy
areare
Oh Super Mario movie that daredevil
darzee 26:10
yeah but [ __ ]
that adds newspaper
now this I've had the crazy ones ah
I didn't even notice it really
cool we're gonna be giving you something
special
Jerry's here he just showed up and
Veronica's here and I want them to watch
this video I just showed them the
Suicide Squad the trailer that this is
making fun of so now it's their turn to
watch this and I really feel like I bet
they're gonna love it I bet they're
gonna love it more than us because I
know Veronica didn't see the Batman V
Superman 1 I know Jerry saw it and he
loved it ok I'm gonna sit in Ryan's
chair now ooh
why do you have a knife here huh do you
have a knife oh that's one happy we'll
get out of hand
yes all right people we Briana well I
always I always forget why he used why
why I just told you
all right guys watch the video
yourselves
hi I'm Ryan Ryan second you're Jerry
Sarah oh wait I want to take my hair
down Simon one thing all of this is
going in the video we're not gonna cut
it ways a surprise oh yeah totally and
yes we all live together yeah this is
actually when you guys leave it's just
like friends in here oh yeah we're just
always coming in the door and people are
cheering just are much lighter than a
toaster yeah okay guys let's do this
uh sorry Ryan right oh wait I'm Barranca
success I'm not Ryan
I'm Darius check us son but I was their
mom the worst of the worst
want to assemble a task force of the
most dangerous people on the planet
wait think and do somebody I think makes
you think you can control because
getting people to act against them
self-interest is what I do for living
now eNOS
everybody loves it but I now understand
then they
that one's got a real
for some kind of Suicide Squad
it's missing the world
yeah
now this I've had the crazy ones huh he
looked so de Tobey Maguire's easy dude I
love just our really really
is that what this came from did did the
douche spider-man walking with the
Suicide Squad come from this video
because I saw that as a gift earlier
today like just I think so ha that's my
friend I loved you spider-man a whole
wide like I'm one of the few people in
this life who like I know spider-man 3
is a mess but that whole douche
spider-man sequence just made me so
happy so what are you doing right why
are you bending reality and move the
camera back so we could uh Breanna and I
could also come in the frame oh yeah
please everyone squeeze in please I'm
Rihanna ladies get closer touchers so
touch each other I mean I mean never
mind I'm trying not to be sexual
actually well we're gonna wrap up like
so unnatural free we're gonna wrap wrap
up this video guys um hey wait a minute
wait a minute you know what I want to
add though what what it's really clever
that he's choosing these comic book
trailers because yet like the same thing
that we would do with a regular comic
book trailer which is look at it frame
by frame and analyze it you would have
to do that to catch all the glimpses
here for example you guys clearly missed
one very important part one very
important part there would have been a
reaction if you had actually I noticed
it if it's not Batman in the newspaper
it's not no oh I look like I hit her gay
what do you guys see oh [ __ ]
hey there's time oh there's you tears
naka song yeah okay so there's javi
Kawai my broseph and those pictures on
the side yeah oh that's cool so we're in
the video in the video not complaining
and I didn't even notice that that's
cool Ali makes
kind of like you know sneaky yeah that's
what I mean it's like you have to go
frame-by-frame in order to catch
everything we did yeah
camel I just hope the next one he does
is a faster trailer yeah all all
throughout the video cuz I feel like
it's camels in nothing like Batman V
Superman worked a little bit better
because that's a faster paced trailer
yes
so like this is a slow trailer so I feel
like a lot of those jokes work when
they're really rapid-fire so like I
didn't goof off as many times this will
right I still I mean it still well me
he's still having fun with like his
after-effects good I think I'm just like
so goofy would it be all these little
effects incredibly like we're seamless
yeah like they look like they belong
there and they make that Camel and then
even though there's no good minion did
you guys see the minions Jimmy even
though they're random it still seems
genuine the placement of all these
things like it seems it seems like he
really does follow his instincts on what
weird thing he are you sure he doesn't
just say let's just throw that there
answer that what do you mean it's
probably just like whatever came to mind
is what he threw yeah exactly and he
follows his gut instinct I'm whatever
the hell he sees randomly there it
doesn't seem like he's forcing this to
happen
yeah you're like not trying to like
really create meaning by well that's the
cool thing is like if one Joker
reference isn't necessarily hit for you
chances are there'll be one coming up
the yeah cuz they're so many good yeah
is there so all over the place some of
them are referential and some of them
are just super wacky you would like a
giant bread roll destroying the city not
that you would have to watch it like a
couple of times so yeah should we catch
everything maybe three times maybe now
the point is it so fun that you don't
mind watching it a few times yes you
know it's like okay and because it's a
comic book trailer that's why we'll be
able to do that because Comper trailers
already make you do that alone yeah yeah
so if you haven't actually seen this
trailer you should actually watch the
region
video so you can see what we're saying
is it's too small to see like all these
little guys like they were tables - yeah
yeah so we highly recommend you would go
to Aldo Joe also and you watch the video
when full screen ok I'll watch it on
full screen yes he gave me permission in
several different ways to use this video
there's something that went over there I
wonder what it is
playback the video we might like it -
yeah
stop it I'm talking about Briana hooking
up with John I mean what a - I'm talking
about Briana hooking up with Jerry right
not you - mmm
I wouldn't like that yeah like on the
show like I wouldn't like that at all
are you trying to get a rise out of me
right now you guys are getting a rise I
trying to get a rise out of all of us
we're all waiting to see who's gonna
blink first all right guys I'm gonna go
along subscribe today become a reject
reasons - Jerry day guess tubs are the
things Jerry has on this channel
veronika six toast has a channel check
it out acoustic covers and vlogs gaming
channel from Brianna the white girl so
make sure to check that out follow us on
our social networks and shout out to
Aldo Jones man you make my combs want to
go went to the Frozone what does that
mean that means he has a huge vagina
cones and then a reference to to the
incredible he said he has a vagina
mystery and vaginas that's where the
vagina is so long in the butthole so big
that its forms one giant vaginas thank
you big ah glad microcurrents the one
who left a fat joke so there's no like
interstitial inter social flesh patch
you think it's just one try that's got
to be horribly on Santa it's very
unsanitary and but there's a special
message right with retracts for lining
yeah let's do this that's yeah careful
there
you